a Dogecoin right this fictional
coin that Elon Musk kind of Pumped up
and stuff right was worth fractions of
pennies is at the peak 81 cents so
you're saying a a I mean shout to
Elon but like but like if you're you're
saying some this fake little meme coin
that literally does nothing it's just a
meme coin which what almost as much as a
dollar with infinite inflation shout to
likecoin but like infinite inflation and
this is the that's so scary and
then on top of that so so they're going
to give this Wick money that's what I'm
going to call it it's going to be Wick
money right they're going to give these
these things here's $1,000 here's th000
th thousand everyone has a th right and
then what'll happen is they'll start
phasing dollars out and then eventually
what it's going to what's going to
happen here is Pearl you can't buy guns
you can't buy this you can't buy that
you